all right so my top number one song of  the summer probably wouldn't be nice  because I used to go on road trips with  my parents and somebody we'd listen to  Pet Sounds into Rubber Soul let me drive  my car would be number two you know how  good that's the first song off the  Rubber Soul  this summer I've been listening to the  Drake mixtape and the Kenton Kendrick to  pimp a butterfly album so I guess  alright by Kendrick I've never had a  buzz cut but um you just brought it up  so I think right after this I'm just  gonna buzz it all off I used to think  that my head might be ship shaped like  an egg but I still might be but my dad's  head is shades and it looks pretty cool  so I think I might I do know two jorts  but yes to Jackies khakis that are short  jockeys jacket  yeah before my hands manhandles hell  another croakies I just think like above  the ankle is weird  yeah so pants full length short so you  piece some people call them pants I  would call them shorts